FRANCESC COMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
49 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good,
thanks, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC COMPOY: Pretty hungry.
Very good, very good.
Actually, very excited
about the interview today
because I'm sure I'm going to
be learning a lot because it's
about a topic I don't
know that much about.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, me neither.
It's all about Windows.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Yeah,
Windows and .NET.
And they only .NET program--
I've actually done some C#
programming and F#, and they're
cool but, that was a long time
ago.
So yeah, I'm looking
forward to these interviews.
MARK MANDEL: I do a little bit
of C# because I'm playing with
Unity these days,
but that's really it.
I mean, that's Unity C#.
I don't know, actually.
I really don't know
if it's different.
FRANCESC COMPOY: No idea.
MARK MANDEL: No idea.
FRANCESC COMPOY:
Never learning Unity.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, but
we have Chris Sells and--
FRANCESC COMPOY: And
Amruta Gulanikar--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, both joining
us today to talk about that.
FRANCESC COMPOY:
Yeah, and at the end
we'll have a question about
those-- what is the name?
Is it Heisenbug, which
is a bug that only occurs
when you're not looking at it?
MARK MANDEL: I did not
know that was a word.
FRANCESC COMPOY: It is a
Heisenbug or something.
MARK MANDEL: Heisenbug or
a Shroedinger's cat bug
or something.
FRANCESC COMPOY: It is pretty
much the same thing, I guess.
So yeah, it is
basically like, OK,
so I have this bug in
production but I'm not able
to [INAUDIBLE] it locally.
It's the opposite of a
works in the-- actually,
no, it works in the machine.
MARK MANDEL: It
works in the machine.
Yes, exactly.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Yeah, so
what do I do with this?
But before that, we will have
a cool thing of the week,
and today we have one cool thing
of the week, which is actually
15 awesome things.
MARK MANDEL: So.
Like, 15 cool
things of the week.
FRANCESC COMPOY: 15
cool things of the week.
That is a record right there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so it's a blog
post written by a Googler
named Tino Tereshko.
He works on big data at Google.
He wrote an article called "15
awesome things you probably
didn't know about
Google BigQuery."
FRANCESC COMPOY: Yeah, and I got
to say that I consider myself
to know a lot about
BigQuery, and there
were things I did not know.
Like one of the
things I did not know
was about how the
storage is automatically
optimized for the way you use
it, which is pretty amazing.
Because, like, when you're
using your computer,
like, a long time
ago and you have
to defragment your
computer, that is basically
something that
happens automatically
in the background, and you don't
even need to care about it.
You just get the performance.
MARK MANDEL: That's very cool.
Well, I read these 15
things, and you wouldn't
believe what happened next.
Sorry, I had to make that joke.
FRANCESC COMPOY:
[INAUDIBLE] next.
MARK MANDEL: No,
it's really cool.
There is definitely
some fun stuff in there.
One of my favorites
is definitely
the whole public data
set aspect of it--
being able to access all sorts
of interesting and exciting
information that's been
available to, well,
basically anyone if you want
to go have a look at it.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Yeah,
there's a bunch of them.
And if you're trying to
get started with BigQuery,
it's definitely a fun
place to get started.
And sometimes even
for some big projects,
those datasets can
be really useful.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
I'll shout out to one here.
There is a GitHub
reliability done out.
One of our good
friends Paul Newson,
he looked at commit
levels within GitHub
to see if he could
determine whether or not
there was an outage at
that given point in time.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: It's a
really cool article.
We'll link to it
in the show notes.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Nice.
Backwords SLA.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
FRANCESC COMPOY:
That is awesome.
Cool, so I think that it's time
to go talk we our friends Chris
and Amruta.
MARK MANDEL: I
think let's do that.
So I'm very pleased
and delighted to have
two guests on our show
today, one of which
is a return guest, which
makes me super, super happy.
We have Chris Sells, lead PM
for Cloud Developer tooling.
We've also got-- oh wow, OK,
I'm going to try my best here--
Amruta Gulanikar.
Is that close enough?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Pretty close.
MARK MANDEL: I'll take close.
I'll take close.
FRANCESC COMPOY: He's normally
pretty bad at any kind of name,
so you know--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah-- who
is product manager for Windows
on Google Compute Engine.
Thank you both for coming.
How are you both doing?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR:
We're doing great.
CHRIS SELLS: Great.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR:
Thanks for having us.
CHRIS SELLS: And good
job pronouncing my name,
by the way.
You did it flawlessly,
no problem.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Chris
Sells [INAUDIBLE].
In Catalan you could
pronounce it "selge" in case
you were wondering.
Anyway, so we're
going to be talking
about Windows and
Windows on Google Cloud
Platform, et cetera.
But before we do that,
why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself?
So we had Chris
before, so we're going
to start with Amruta this time.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR:
OK, hi everyone.
Pleased to be here.
So I joined Google
from Microsoft
where I worked on different
office products at Microsoft,
and very recently launched
a new service for Office 365
right before coming to Google.
I've been at Google-- I've
worked on the customer success
team the first
year, and now I am
the PM for making Windows
awesome on Google Cloud
Compute.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And you, Chris?
CHRIS SELLS: Well, I
like that awesomeness.
I like to try to bring
a little bit of awesome
into the work I do,
too, just like Amruta.
My background is I spent a good
20 plus years as a contributing
member of the Windows
developer community,
focused on developer
tools and books.
And in fact, I spent
eight years at Microsoft.
The last two, I was
on the Visual Studio
team working on the Windows
8 developer experience.
And I joined Google--
in fact, in about a week
it will be my two-year
Googleversary.
And I have been working on Cloud
Developer tooling since then,
including, like Amruta, making
windows and .NET awesome
on our platform.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Nice.
So since you are both big in
the Windows this community,
we could say, why don't you
tell us if I was a Windows
developer, like, everything I've
done so far is developing apps
on Windows, using Windows
technologies like, let's say,
I don't know, C# and SQL Server.
How do I get started on
the Google Cloud Platform?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Great, so
if you're a Windows developer
and you're steeped in
Windows technologies,
a great place to start is
by creating an account.
We have a wide range of
images, both Windows Server
as well a SQL Server, that
we support today on GCE.
I would really
encourage someone who
wants to get their feet wet
to sign up for an account.
All our images are a
part of the free trial,
including the SQL Server
images, so that's a great way
to kind of get started, boot
up a Windows VM or a SQL VM,
get one of your ASP.NET
applications over, and try out.
And as you're doing that, I
think an important piece is not
only the fact that we
support these pay-as-you-go,
per-minute, with license
included images for these
server technologies, but
we also have a great,
rich set of dev tools that
you can use as you're building
your ASP.NET applications
or moving over your ASP.NET
applications.
And Chris is the best person
to talk about all the great
support we're building there.
CHRIS SELLS: Yeah, I mean, if
I was a .NET developer trying
to get a handle on
Windows and .NET on GCP,
there's two places I would go.
Both of them start with the
same place-- cloud.google.com,
like all GCP goodness.
And so cloud.google.com/windows
provides kind of an overview
why you would care about Windows
on our platform and links
to various resources on how to
get started and read the docs
and things like that.
And then
cloud.google.com/dotnet--
D-O-T N-E-T. And we've got
a quick start tutorial there
and a bunch of follow-on
tutorials and links
to the tools, our
Visual Studio plug-in,
our PowerShell extension,
all of our libraries--
all of the kind of developer
stuff you need to get started
on our platform from ground zero
you can find all on that page.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Nice.
So one of the
things that I really
like about our offer
on Windows-- which
I wish we had it on
Linux-- it is the fact
that when you create
a new instance, when
you choose Windows, it actually
comes directly with RDP.
The fact that you can connect
to it-- have you ever done that?
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah, so
you can actually have a GUI
and, like, see it?
FRANCESC COMPOY: Yes.
I think that is pretty amazing.
Like, you just click the button.
MARK MANDEL: Linux users
live on the command line.
FRANCESC COMPOY: I know.
CHRIS SELLS: Well,
so by the way,
I'm a huge fan of that feature
and we like that feature
so much that we actually built
into our Visual Studio plug-in.
So if you install the
Visual Studio plug-in,
of course you can deploy your
code using the standard web
deployment
technologies, and we'll
help you with that from
inside of Visual Studio,
but we also provide
the Cloud Explorer,
and the Cloud
Explorer allows you
to see and browse and manage
your various cloud project
resources.
And one of those sets of
resources that we support
is, of course, your machines.
So if you want to,
you can right-click
on any of those machines
that are associated
with your project
and say, oh gosh,
I'd like to just-- I don't
remember the IP address,
I just want to surf
to this machine
so it will bring up
the browser and you
can surf to that machine.
Or you can start and stop
it and all those things
that you would expect to do.
But one of my favorites is to
be able to right-click on it
and say, oh, I just
want to RDP into this.
And so it'll just fire up
the terminal services client
and off you go.
FRANCESC COMPOY:
That is very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Now I have to
ask because I'm curious now.
Can you do that from mobile?
Because you can SSA tutorial
Linux VM from mobile,
but you can you, like,
RDP in from mobile?
CHRIS SELLS: You absolutely can.
In fact--
MARK MANDEL: No way!
CHRIS SELLS: Yeah,
you totally can.
There are Android RDP
clients, and you can totally
RDP into any Windows machine,
including ones running on GCP.
FRANCESC COMPOY: That
is pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: And as
much as I love the RDP thing
and I think everyone
should try it,
for folks who want
to be command prompt
and who want to manage
remotely, we also
are going to support
Windows WinRM so that you
can kind of log in, run a bunch
of your PowerShell commands
remotely to manage, like, your
fleet of Windows machines.
A really cool thing is also,
like, hey people start up VMs
and you definitely want
to RDP into it and say,
hey, I can connect to my VM
and yeah, things are good,
that's awesome.
But if things don't
look good, you also
want to see, hey, what's the
serial console output, right?
And we have that right
there in our Cloud Console
you can click on
serial console access
and kind of see what's
going on with your VM.
Did it boot correctly, did the
license get assigned correctly,
is it authenticated,
and so on and so forth.
So lots of great tools
and ways in which
you can spin up your Windows
VMs and see that things
are working well.
FRANCESC COMPOY: So
after what you said,
I have, like, 100 questions.
The first one being you
mentioned PowerShell, and that
made me think about
the fact that now you
can run Bash on
Windows apparently,
but only on some versions of it.
MARK MANDEL: Windows 10.
FRANCESC COMPOY: So what
are the versions supported
on Google Cloud Platform?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: So we support
the Server OS's, and so we
have Windows Server 2008 and
2012 R2, and as of last week,
Windows Server 2016
Data Center Edition.
So we launched five days after
they [INAUDIBLE] the bits.
We're very happy to do that.
We've been in very
close partnership.
So we have the latest and
greatest Windows Server
versions on Google Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Since we're
talking about Windows versions,
I know we also
support SQL Server.
What versions of SQL
Server do we support?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Yes,
that's a great question.
So we support the
different editions
and different versions.
So we definitely have
support for standard web
and express all in GA.
We are actively working on
getting SQL Server Enterprise
out.
It's already in alpha.
We're testing it with
a couple of customers.
And we have a wide
range of versions
along with the additions I just
mentioned, so we have support
from 2012, 2014, and the
latest and greatest, 2016.
We also support SQL Server
2016 on Windows Server
2016 as of last week.
So we are pretty excited to
have a really broad range
of editions and
versions that people
can choose to spin up on us.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Cool.
So then if I'm a Windows
developer with a C#
application, I can deploy a
new Windows instance and deploy
my code into that one,
and start running it.
Can I run it on Linux, too?
Could you explain what is the
difference between running a C#
application on Linux or Windows?
I know that C# now
runs on Linux, too,
because it's open-source.
CHRIS SELLS: Yeah, so we're
focused a lot on this,
on the tooling side.
Of course we want to make sure
that people coming to Google
have a great experience
on our machines,
and we work hard
to make sure we've
got wonderful distributions
that run great on our platform
for both Linux and
Windows Server.
And our tutorials know that 99%
of the world out there today
is using ASP.NET, they're
targeting Windows,
and so it's ASP.NET 4.x.
And of course, we built all
our tools and our tutorials
all around that, right?
Making sure that you can deploy
to Windows Server instances
running ASP.NET and
IAS the way you expect.
That said, we're also working
really hard on supporting .NET
Core, which is the
cross-platform version of .NET.
It's kind of the follow-on
to the .NET that is
Windows-specific that
Microsoft has released
into the open-source and that
we've been working to support
on our cloud.
And in fact, if you
go to the GCP blog,
there have been some recent
articles about how to take
your .NET Core code and make it
work on App Engine Flex on GCP
and on Container Engine
on GCP using Kubernetes.
And so the way that works is
you take your .NET Core code
and you package it up with a
base Docker image that supports
the .NET Core runtime.
And then you can bundle
all that together
and you can deploy it to App
Engine Flex or Kubernetes
running on Container Engine.
So you can do that today.
There's nothing stopping you.
The set of libraries
that we support,
we're working hard to make
sure that you can do all that.
All the code you want to write
against our libraries works
in the Windows version
of .NET, of course,
and that's 200 plus APIs
across all of Google.
This is not just BigQuery
and Cloud Storage,
although, of
course, we do those,
too, all the cloud stuff.
But it's also locations
and maps and, you know,
G-Drive and Docs and
all the wonderful APIs
that people use across Google.
We have support for that
100% inside of Windows.
And that same set of APIs, we
have about 99% coverage right
now for .NET Core.
It's not quite 100%.
We're busy updating our
GRPC implementation, which
is based around HTTP2.
It's binary, it's
streaming, it's faster.
And the libraries that require
that protocol don't yet work
for .NET Core, but
we're so close.
We're so close to
making that work.
So I expect very soon--
hopefully by the end
of the year, certainly by Q1--
that 100% of all of our APIs
will work in .NET Core, too.
Which means that you can,
in Visual Studio or VS Code
on Linux, Mac, or Windows, write
your .NET Core application,
you can use Nougat to bring in
the Google .NET Core libraries,
write your code and deploy it
to App Engine Flexible Edition
or Container Engine
running Kubernetes,
and it'll just work.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
All right, so I'm going to ask
a question that I know-- well,
so I do some game
development stuff.
Any idea if it'll work
in Unity, the C# stuff?
CHRIS SELLS: Ah, good question.
Unity is an open question
for us because, of course,
we want to support Unity.
Unity has a fabulous library
environment for doing
.NET-based development.
So we want to make
sure we support it.
Unfortunately, right
now, Unity is .NET 2.x.
And they're moving to
.NET 4.x with Mono.
So as soon as they've moved
there and we have a reasonable
platform, because I admit, we
don't support .NET all the way
back to 2.0.
MARK MANDEL: Not
many people do, which
is why I asked the question.
CHRIS SELLS: But when Unity
comes along with a more modern
version of .NET, then we're
going to see what we can do
about supporting it because
we want Unity games to be able
to use the Google Cloud
Platform, as well.
MARK MANDEL: That
makes me happy.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Cool,
so if I'm not mistaken,
everything that we've been
talking about for containers
was on Linux containers.
What about Windows containers?
Because I've read
somewhere that they exist.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Definitely.
Windows containers is
definitely interesting,
and we are keeping
a close eye on it.
The step 1 in actually
supporting Windows Containers
is to support Windows Server
2016, which we have done.
We're also working very actively
on supporting Windows Nano
images.
So this would help
accelerate people actually
being able to deploy these
container images on a smaller
footprint of Windows,
which is Windows Nano
2016, the preferred
OS for data centers,
much faster, smaller
footprint, so on and so forth.
So we're actively building
the support in the platform
first, so we're definitely
working on that.
In parallel, we're deeply
engaged with the community
on, sort of, building support
for Windows containers
in Kubernetes.
So you will probably see some
interesting things come out
there pretty soon.
And we're sort of
waiting and watching
and kind of looking at the
customer adoption for Windows
containers.
There are pretty new and
shiny, and a lot of people
are excited about it, so we're
keeping a close pulse on that.
And we definitely want
to take that feedback
as we kind of think
about building support
in GKE for that.
But I think, to be very
honest, we are kind of
wanting to wait and see how
people start using our Windows
2016 images, Nano
images, and then
the excitement in the Kubernetes
community around Windows
containers are definitely
going to be things that help
us decide what to do next here.
FRANCESC COMPOY:
So for people that
don't know that much
about Windows containers,
other than they
exist-- like me--
what is the main difference?
Is there a
technological difference
on the type of container it
is, or is it just a base image,
which is completely different?
CHRIS SELLS: So here's how
to think about it, kind of,
in the big picture.
If you think about the
idea of Linux containers
as being kind of a
lighter-weight containment
protocol for your
applications, where
you can pack multiple containers
on top of a single VM that
have access to shared resources
like the operating system
image and the hard drive,
but these are still
environments that are
isolated from each other,
the idea, of course,
is that you can
stack multiple of
these containers
into a single virtual
machine and get the most
out of the resources
of that machine
without having to open
up the hole of having
these things break
their boundaries
and talk to each other or try
to crack or hack each other.
If you think about that,
well, Linux containers
are just containers that
have a shared Linux base,
and your code runs assuming
Linux is under there.
And Windows containers is just
your Windows code in a Windows
container that has a shared
access to the set of resources
inside of Windows.
So while conceptually
they are the same,
of course your code has to
run on Linux or Windows,
and you have to think about
it differently and write
your code differently.
But the nice thing is that
Microsoft has worked hard
with Docker to make sure that
the same set of tools that you
use for managing
Linux containers
can also be used to
manage Windows containers.
Which means that from
a tooling point of view
and an orchestration
point of view--
for example, that's what
Kubernetes is all about,
right, orchestrating
containers--
you can think of about
them in the same way,
which is really nice.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Nice.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I think that's great.
All right, so I think it's
time-- this is the Google Cloud
Platform Podcast where
we ask the hard questions
and we talk a little bit about
the elephant in the room.
More often than not,
when people think
of running Windows in the cloud,
they think of Microsoft Azure.
Why should people
come to us instead?
Like, is there, like,
philosophical differences
or other differences
that they should
be aware of when making a
decision on where they should
be running in the cloud?
CHRIS SELLS: Well, certainly
from the Windows world
and from the Microsoft
world even more,
both Amruta and I have some
kind of understanding of the way
that the Windows community
thinks about these things
and the, kind of,
open-source community
thinks about these things.
And for a long time these
were different communities.
The Windows people did it
the way Microsoft said,
and there was enterprises
that, kind of, were
encouraged to do
things a certain way
with certain set of tools.
And here, over in
the Google world,
we're much more
open about things.
We are heavily involved with
open-source and open standards.
And so certainly
on Azure, you're
encouraged to do
things very much
the same old Microsoft way that
you've done them before, which
has its pluses and minuses.
Here in the Google world,
we're much more open.
We're much less about
you come to our platform
and then you're locked in.
You can't go anywhere else.
For example, we were just
talking about containers,
right?
The idea of a container is
you can run that container
where you want it, right?
Where it runs best.
And because we've built
our Container Engine, which
is our orchestration platform
for containers on our platform,
based on open standards--
Docker containers,
Kubernetes-- we
very much encourage
you to bring your
container-based workloads
to our platform.
But if you don't like it here,
you can take them other places.
Lots of people run Kubernetes
on other cloud providers,
lots of people run
Kubernetes on-premise,
and, in fact, lots of people
run Kubernetes between the cloud
and on-premise depending
on the resources they need
and the access they
need for their software,
and you can more easily
go back and forth.
And so at Google, instead of
to lock you into how you do
things, we try to
make sure that we're
the best place to run those open
things so that we try to earn
your business every day.
So that's one way of saying it.
Another way of
saying it is we think
there's a bunch of stuff on our
platform that is just better.
We have more choices,
we have more options
to make it easier to spend less
money to run your stuff more
efficiently.
Of course we're the world
leader in big data and machine
learning, and of course you
get Google's amazing networking
and infrastructure when
you come to our platform.
So I think that the Google Cloud
Platform is a fabulous choice
whether you're a Linux developer
or a Windows developer.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Yeah,
that's exactly right.
And just to kind of chime
in, I couldn't agree more
with Chris over there.
We also offer our pricing.
Our promise to our customers
is we make improvements
in running our data centers.
We pass along those
savings to you guys.
And our Windows pricing
for our Windows VMs
is extremely competitive, even
with existing cloud providers
like Azure and AWS.
We also have great innovation
on platform sides, which
customers, both
Windows and Linux,
can leverage, like custom VMs.
So you're no longer paying for
the license costs for the cores
that you don't use.
You can have machine shapes
exactly with the number
of cores that you want, the
memory you want, and pay
exactly for that, passing along
more savings to your customers.
So I think as we
innovate, we offer
a large variety of supports and
tools and images for Windows,
as well as these
platform improvements,
we'll just keep making sure
that you get the | experience
running your workloads on us.
MARK MANDEL: So in our notes I
have a thing about PowerShell
and open-source.
And I'm happy to admit
that I know nothing
about either of them.
So it sounds like there's
something interesting there.
Chris, do you want to
tell us what's going on?
CHRIS SELLS: Well, of
course you know a great deal
about open-source, but I think
what you mean is PowerShell
plus open-source together.
I mean, let me back right up.
So the idea of PowerShell
is that it's the shell
that Windows developers and
IT administrators specifically
use because it is essentially
a really great way
to interactively understand
and manage various resources.
So for example, if I've
got a cloud provider that
provides a set of
commandlets, or if I've
got a piece of software
that has an administration
interface, by having
a set of commandlets,
I can, with a very easy set
of commands that I already
probably know, a set of standard
verbs across everything,
I can say I want to
be able to create
an instance of this
resource, I want
to be the list, the set
of resources of this type,
I want to be able to
remove them or update them.
You know, the standard
kind of CRUD style
is baked right
into the verbs that
are part of PowerShell,
which is great
because it makes it super
easy to use and learn
new sets of commandlets.
And now there are
tens of thousands
of these commandlets for
various pieces of software
in the world in the
Windows community.
The other thing that
makes it really great
is as you interact
with these resources,
you get lists of
resources or lists
of what look like normal
lines like he would
in Bash or your
standard Unix shell,
but that's only
how it's rendered.
What you're actually getting
back is sets of objects,
and you can pipe these objects
from one command to another.
And PowerShell is
really a language
for manipulating objects.
What it means is that
unlike in the Unix world,
you don't have to do
regular expression matching
to be able to pull out various
bits and pieces of the data
as it goes by, you can just
look at object properties
and you can call object
methods in a way that
is very easy for
developers to understand.
And IT administrators
have really
fallen in love with this.
And so when I say that
Google Cloud Platform has
an initial set of commandlets
for a number of our most
popular resources, everyone
that does PowerShell and wants
to use it with
GCP is immediately
interested and excited
and understands
the benefits and power of that.
So that's the base.
Now, what does it mean when
we talk about PowerShell
and open-source?
Well, Microsoft has
been busy pushing
a lot of their tools
and technologies
into the open-source world.
C# is open-source, MSBuild,
Visual Studio Code.
.NET itself has been
made open-source.
And one of the things
that they've recently
made open-source is PowerShell.
And not only have they
made it open-source,
but they've made
it cross-platform.
So you can, in fact, take
PowerShell, that same kind
of shell experience
with well-known verbs
in the piping of objects
from one command to another,
and you can run that in a
Linux world or on your Mac.
And so what that means, then,
is for all the commandments
to come along, the
commandlet providers
have to also support
versions of their commandlets
that are cross-platform.
And so when Microsoft made
this initial announcement
for an open-source,
cross-platform version
of PowerShell, they
reached out to us,
and we've been
partnering with them.
And we're one of a
very small handful
of companies that are actually
on the leading edge here.
We had advanced access
to these technologies,
and we're well down
the path of making
our same set of commandlets
available to PowerShell
on Windows to making
them available for Linux
and the Mac, as well.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Nice.
So it sounds like
we're in a world where
you can use PowerShell on
Linux and Bash on Windows.
CHRIS SELLS: Yeah.
Exactly right.
FRANCESC COMPOY: That
is pretty amazing.
CHRIS SELLS: In
fact, if you wanted,
you could run Bash on
Windows and then use
the Linux version of the
PowerShell commandlets
on Bash on Windows.
MARK MANDEL: And then to run
.NET inside of Linux, as well.
CHRIS SELLS: To run .NET inside
of the Linux that runs inside
of the Windows if
you wanted, yes.
FRANCESC COMPOY:
OK, I think it is
time to stop this conversation.
But before we finish,
is there any topic
that you would like to discuss?
Something that we
may have missed.
CHRIS SELLS: Oh, there
is just one thing
that I'm super excited about
that we just recently did.
Jon Skeet talked about it in
a keynote he did last week.
And for Windows-based
listeners, Jon Skeet, of course,
needs no introduction.
He's number one for
reputation on Stack Overflow.
So of all the people on Stack
Overflow, he's the first,
and he's a Google employee,
and he works on my team working
on all those great libraries
that I was talking about
to make sure that all of
our stuff is accessible from
Windows and from .NET Core.
And he was busy showing
off his brand new feature.
We took .NET Core and we made
it one of the default runtimes
available in the Cloud Shell.
You guys know what
the Cloud Shell is?
FRANCESC COMPOY: Yeah, we've
discussed a little bit.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, the
interactive development
environment that you
can access straight
from the website for the
developer console for cloud
FRANCESC COMPOY: Which
is pretty awesome.
CHRIS SELLS: Yeah, so the
command line in the cloud
is the Cloud Shell,
and it comes packed
with all of your
language tools, it
comes with your Python
tools and your node tools.
And it's got both kinds
of editors-- it's got VI
and it's got Emacs, so you
can do all your stuff there.
We just recently added
a web-based editor.
We're hosting the
open-source Orion editor
so you can have access via
graphical editor to all
the files in your disk
while you're in Cloud Shell.
But we just recently, and
again, within the last few days,
added all the .NET tools.
So that means that you
can say dotnet-new-- I
want a brand new hunk of code.
Then I can say
dotnet-restore, dotnet-run.
I can host my .NET Core app
inside of the Cloud Shell
and see it run, and then I can
use the Orion editor to edit
it.
And then I can package
it up and ship it off
to App Engine all
inside the browser
without having to use anything.
You could do the whole thing
on a Chromebook if you wanted.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Amruta, have you got
anything else to add?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: No,
it's hard to top that.
But we're working on it, Chris.
We'll have something
pretty cool soon.
CHRIS SELLS: Oh, we already
have something cool.
We just shipped Windows Server
2016 within days of Microsoft
making it GA.
That by itself is cool.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Yeah, and we
are gonna have support for Nano
by the end of the
year, too, which
we're super proud of
the relationship we have
with Microsoft and
the fact that we're
working on builds [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS SELLS: That's great.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Awesome.
Maybe we'll have you back then.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Yeah.
CHRIS SELLS: That
would be great.
Always happy to come back.
FRANCESC COMPOY: That
would be awesome.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
to talk to us today about
all the Windows things.
CHRIS SELLS: Happy.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you very much.
FRANCESC COMPOY: So
thanks again both
to Chris Sells and
Amruta Gulanikar.
It was a pleasure
to have Chris back.
It's been a long time.
He was here for episode number
5, and he's back for episode
almost 50.
And yeah, thank you
again to Amruta, too.
Maybe we'll have her again
in a couple hundred episodes.
Who knows so many
episodes so far?
Anyway, I think it's time to go
with the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
let's talk about that.
So this is a great
example of, I think,
something that's
happened to all of us.
It works fine on my machine, but
then you put it into production
and something goes haywire.
There's a bug in the code,
maybe there's a threading issue.
That's always the fun
one that always bites me.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Oh yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Or just something
weird that you never even
thought of.
Is there a way I can
go through and debug it
in a way that lets me
see what's going on
inside the application?
FRANCESC COMPOY: So the
interesting thing is that you
cannot really debug it because
a debugger basically stops
a process, so if you do that
on your production jobs,
then it's not going
to work very well.
MARK MANDEL: That generally
is pretty bad, yeah.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Yeah,
that is a bad idea.
So the solution to
that is very often
add loglines everywhere to
understand what's going on,
right?
MARK MANDEL: I've done that.
FRANCESC COMPOY:
Yeah, me too, but that
is actually kind of painful
because you need to redeploy
your app and stuff like that.
There's actually much
better way, which
is using Stackdrive Debugger.
And Stackdriver Debugger-- even
though it's called Debugger,
I'd rather not
call it a debugger
because instead what
it does, it just
takes snapshots of your
job running in production
so you can get the stack
trace of the whole thing that
is executing, and also the
values of the variables
defined, which means that
you can basically have, like,
a snapshot of the whole
status of your server
at the moment you care about.
MARK MANDEL: So it
should really be
called the Stackdriver,
like, Snapshotter.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Snapshotter.
That sounds actually
really cool.
Yeah, so the cool thing about
it is that it used to be beta,
it is now GA.
So give it a try.
I know that I've used it in Go,
not for App Engine because Go
on App Engine still doesn't
work, but we're working on it,
but it does work for Go
on Kubernetes-- well,
on GKE and on GCE.
So if you have some
application there,
it actually works really well.
MARK MANDEL: And if
you're a Java, Python,
or Node aficionado, it
works across Google App
Engine as well as Compute Engine
and Container Engine, as well.
FRANCESC COMPOY:
So yeah, definitely
worth checking it out.
Next time you have a
bug and you don't really
know how to fix it, just try
the Debugger, get all the data,
and then be able to
reproduce it locally.
Most of the time that will work.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So before we wrap up,
Francesc, what are you up to?
Where are you going?
What are you doing?
FRANCESC COMPOY: So I
just released finally
the latest episode
of JustForFunc.
Again, a code review,
and people are liking it.
Got a lot of feedback,
most of it positive.
MARK MANDEL: That's good.
It's YouTube, you can
only expect so much.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Yeah.
And I'm going to be working
on the next episode,
but also next week
I'm going to Brazil,
and I'm going to Brazil
for the first time.
Very excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC COMPOY: I'm going to
be speaking at GopherCon Brazil,
which is in Florianopolis.
And then after that, I
will be, on November 10th,
at GCP Next Sao Paolo.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC COMPOY: So yeah,
it's going to be lots of fun.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So yeah,
I'll be at Gam3rCon game
conference in Atlantic City
on the 28th of October.
Now, I was supposed to not
be traveling in November,
but I managed to snag a ticket
to Unite, the Unity conference,
so I will be there just
attending, having a good time.
So please feel free
to come and say hello.
FRANCESC COMPOY: Sounds
like lots of fun.
Well, thank you again for
having the time to teach me
some Windows today, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: I had nothing to do
with that, that was our guests.
But yes, thank you so much for
joining me, as well, Francesc.
FRANCESC COMPOY: And thank
you all for listening in.
MARK MANDEL: All right,
and see you all next week.